Su empresa realiza una búsqueda para un puesto vacante.
Las solicitudes empiezan a llegar
y se identifican los candidatos que dan el perfil.
Empieza la selección.
Primer candidato: universidad de élite, notas excelentes, currículo impecable,
referencias excelentes.
Todo lo ideal.
Segundo candidato: escuela pública, inestabilidad en sus puestos de trabajo
con trabajos ocasionales como cajera y camarera cantante.
Pero recuerden, ambos están cualificados.
Así que les pregunto:
¿a quién elegirían?
Mis colegas y yo creamos un conjunto de términos muy técnicos
para describir 2 categorías distintas de candidatos.
Llamamos al primero: "la cuchara de plata",
uno que tuvo todas las ventajas y estuvo destinado para el éxito.
Llamamos a B: "el luchador",
uno que tuvo que pelear contra viento y marea
para llegar al mismo punto.
Sí, acaban de escuchar a una directora de RR. HH. referirse a la gente
como cucharas y luchador...
(Risas)
lo que no es políticamente correcto y suena un poco sesgado.
Pero, antes de revocar mis credenciales en RR.HH. ...
(Risas)
permítanme explicarme.
Un currículo cuenta una historia.
Y con los años, he aprendido algo sobre las personas
cuyas experiencias son muy similares a un mosaico de los más variopinto.
Eso me anima a considerarlas detenidamente
antes de desechar sus currículos.
Una serie de trabajos temporales pueden indicar inconsistencia,
falta de concentración, imprevisibilidad.
O puede señalar compromiso y perseverancia.
Como mínimo, el luchador merece una entrevista.
Para que quede claro,
no tengo nada en contra los cuchara de plata;
ingresar y graduarse en una universidad de élite
requiere mucho trabajo duro y sacrificio.
Pero si toda tu vida ha sido orientada al éxito,
¿cómo afrontarás los momentos difíciles?
Un empleado sintió que por haber estudiado en una gran universidad,
había ciertas tareas que no estaban a su altura,
por ejemplo, un trabajo manual para comprender mejor una operación.
Al final renunció.
Pero, por el otro lado,
¿qué sucede cuando toda una vida está condenada al fracaso
y al final se alcanza el éxito?
Les pido encarecidamente que entrevisten al luchador.
Sé mucho sobre este tema porque yo misma lo fui.
Antes de nacer,
mi padre fue diagnosticado con esquizofrenia paranoide
y no podía mantener un empleo a pesar de ser brillante.
Nuestras vidas eran una mezcla de "Alguien voló sobre el nido del cuco",
un poco de "Despertares"
y un poco de "Una Mente Brillante".
(Risas)
Soy la cuarta de 5 hijos criados por una madre soltera
en un barrió peligroso de Brooklyn, Nueva York.
Nunca tuvimos una casa, un coche o una lavadora,
y durante gran parte de mi infancia, no tuvimos siquiera teléfono.
Así que estaba muy motivada
para entender la relación entre el éxito empresarial y los luchadores
porque mi vida podría haber seguido un curso muy diferente.
Al conocer hombres de negocios exitosos
y leer perfiles de líderes poderosos,
me di cuenta de que tenían algo en común.
Muchos se enfrentaron a dificultades desde una edad temprana,
desde pobreza, abandono,
pérdida temprana de un padre,
hasta trastornos de aprendizaje, alcoholismo y violencia.
La mentalidad convencional sugiere que el trauma acaba en sufrimiento
y se ha puesto mucho énfasis en los trastornos que esto produce.
Sin embargo, los estudios sobre el tema, revelaron un aspecto inesperado:
que aun las peores circunstancias pueden resultar en crecimiento y transformación.
Se ha descubierto un fenómeno notable y algo contradictorio,
que los científicos denominan crecimiento postraumático.
En un estudio diseñado para medir
los efectos de la adversidad sobre niños en situación de riesgo,
entre un subconjunto de 698 niños
que vivieron las condiciones más severas y extremas,
un tercio llego a tener una vida adulta sana, productiva y exitosa.
Y triunfaron a pesar de todo y contra todo pronóstico.
¡Un tercio!
Veamos este currículo.
Los padres de este chico lo dieron en adopción.
Nunca terminó la universidad.
Fue de un empleo a otro,
vivió en la India por un año,
y, por si fuera poco, tiene dislexia.
¿Contratarían a este tipo?
Se llama Steve Jobs.
Un estudio sobre los empresarios de mayor éxito en el mundo
muestra que muchos de ellos tienen dislexia.
En EE. UU.,
un 35 % de los empresarios tenía dislexia.
Y lo más extraordinario es que los empresarios
que experimentaron crecimiento postraumático,
ven su discapacidad de aprendizaje
como una dificultad necesaria que les ofreció una ventaja,
ya que se han convertido en mejores oyentes
que prestan más atención a los detalles.
Ellos no creen que son lo que son a pesar de la adversidad,
sino que saben que son lo que son debido a la adversidad.
Aceptaron sus traumas e infortunios
como elementos clave de lo que han llegado a ser
y saben que, sin esas experiencias,
no podrían haber desarrollado la fuerza y el valor necesarios
para tener éxito.
La vida de uno de mis colegas dio un giro total
debido a la Revolución Cultural China de 1966.
A la edad de 13, sus padres fueron trasladados a un pueblo,
las escuelas se cerraron
mientras que él quedó solo en Beijing para valerse por sí mismo hasta los 16,
y encontró un empleo en una fábrica de ropa.
Pero en vez de aceptar su destino,
tomó la decisión de continuar sus estudios.
11 años más tarde, cuando el panorama político cambió,
se enteró de una prueba de acceso a una universidad extremadamente selecta.
Tuvo 3 meses para preparar todas las asignaturas
de la escuela primaria y secundaria.
Así que, todos los días al regresar de la fábrica a casa,
hacía una siesta, estudiaba hasta las 4 de la mañana,
volvía a trabajar
e hizo lo mismo cada día, durante tres meses.
Y lo consiguió.
Su dedicación a su educación fue absoluta, nunca perdió la esperanza.
Ha acabado un máster
y sus hijas se graduaron en Cornell y Harvard.
Los luchadores tienen la convicción
de que la única persona que puedes realmente controlar eres tú mismo.
Cuando las cosas no salen bien,
se preguntan, "¿Qué puedo cambiar para lograr un mejor resultado?".
Tienen una determinación
que les impide rendirse,
algo así como, "Si he sobrevivido
a la pobreza, a un padre loco y a varios robos",
y luego te enfrentas a "retos laborales"...
(Risas)
¿De veras?
"Pan comido, puedo hacerlo”.
(Risas)
Y eso me recuerda el humor.
Los luchadores saben que el humor ayuda en los momentos difíciles,
y la risa los ayuda a cambiar la perspectiva.
Y por último, las relaciones.
Los que superan la adversidad, no lo hacen solos.
En alguna parte, por el camino,
encuentran personas que despiertan lo mejor de ellos
y que están interesadas en su éxito.
Tener a alguien con quien se puede contar en cualquier situación
es esencial para superar la adversidad.
Yo tuve suerte.
En mi primer trabajo después de la graduación,
no tenía coche,
así que lo compartí con una mujer que era la asistente del presidente.
Ella me vio trabajar
y me animó a centrarme en mi futuro y no vivir en el pasado.
En el camino he conocido a muchos
que me han criticado totalmente honestamente,
asesorado y guiado.
A estas personas no les interesa
que una vez trabajé como camarera cantante para pagar mis estudios.
(Risas)
Los dejo con una última observación valiosa.
Las compañías comprometidas con la inclusión y la diversidad
tienden a apoyar a los luchadores
y a superar los competidores.
Según la revista DiversityInc,
un estudio de las 50 mejores empresas pro diversidad
superaron el índice S&P 500 en un 25 %.
Así que, de vuelta a mi primera pregunta:
¿Por quién apostarán:
por la cuchara de plata o por el luchador?
Yo digo, elijan al candidato subestimado,
cuyas armas secretas son la pasión y la determinación.
Contraten al luchador.
(Aplausos)